so I'm at this dinner with a bunch of
college seniors and they're all talking
about how they want to get into
entrepreneurship that they're
entrepreneurs they're starting their
business and I was like hey man I talked
to you six months ago so where are you
at with that business he's like ah you
know I'm still getting uh my LLC set up
what dude that's not starting a business
that's like being able to have a
business there are four steps to start a
business that anyone can do step one get
an articles incorporation that you can
get online step two take those out of
incorporation to go to a bank and open a
bank account step three connect payment
processor to said bank account to
collect money step four provide value to
a stranger in exchange for money that's
it and they could have done all of those
things in the time that they were
talking about the business that they
wanted to start